auch ich werde mich also mein name ist
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge turbo diesmal das heutige auto ist
ein auto mit dem ich selber sehr oft
auch zur arbeit fahre uns war das hier
allein kopf sorgen ich sitze auch wieder
sehr ästhetisch in gewinnen und es ist
so kritisch dass das meine ich habe
daraus gefordert sich auch andere sachen
nehmen lieber am 1
diese spiele zu alt und wieder spitze
sein kopf ist ganz im körper verboten
das ist ein fetter luca im einkaufswagen
und gibt jetzt gas
über mich drüber ein tränchen
wenn ich mein karachi
ich kann sogar auswählen dass er jetzt
diese andere strecke gefahren so das
heißt wir geben jetzt hier einfach mal
gas und schauen ob frei leisten
bordstein verdammte scheiße ist er denn
dumm ich geb extra als strecke ein er
soll den bahnhof barocker um das ganze
zu analysieren die eigentlichen strecke
war erfährt hier los und fährt hier
landtag über die rampe dahinter und was
macht lukas sasse luca das ist also
wirklich ein blogger das für seinen
einkauf fang nicht gekriegt dann habe
ich mir gedacht wir holen einen alten
freund zurück den kennt ihr vielleicht
sogar aus der letzten folge der hat in
der letzten vor auf jeden fall richtig
rasiert auch ich werde mich wer ist das
denn behinderte mensch agiert denn alles
scho ghört diese scheiß rampe zu treffen
man das ist also spitze klasse ich bin
begeistert ich kann das teil ja sogar
selber lenken dann heißt
das hier ist luca in seiner fahrprüfung
meine damen und herren ja wir fahren
immer schön langsam an luca das machst
du super sei jetzt schon auf die straße
achten auf jeden fall auf der rechten
spur bleiben das ist das wichtige loca
loca bleibe auf der rechten spur fangen
jetzt einfach mal an selber flächen kopf
rechts rum
ist nicht mehr schön jetzt übrig sei
allerdings eine lampe ich dachte es wäre
sehr sinnvoll denn die die anleuchten
aber wenn man das macht ja es macht
tatsächlich gar kein unterschied ich sag
euch folgende es liegt am charakter ich
mache jetzt hier mal hier den hier der
sieht jetzt aus wie ein skelett lenken
to diesmal die tage von alleine und als
auto nehme ich jetzt einfach mal hier
sonne gelände doch ihre gelände karte
und das heißt eigentlich wenn ich jetzt
mal so ein bisschen hier wirklich gas
geben
als ob das so unspektakulär war klasse
recht einsame spitze da sie mit allem
nicht so funktioniert wie essen
vorgestellt
warum für euch diesen kanal warum spiele
ich dieses spiel könnte das kann ich
seiner gucke ich auf meinem bildschirm
und stehe noch aus los mit dem traktor
wir trifft und abfahren morgen fahren in
form bringen uns und die runde vorbei da
das ist der letzte rest habe ich mich
für diese kombination hier entschieden
habe ich ja den sack mit einer tollen
pose auf einem skateboard das ist da
dass das wird das schaffen wir
ich lenke dieser mit einer first person
camera work in slate ist eben drum
was habe ich getan ich will wiederholung
hier bin ich losgefahren wusste dann
nicht wo der hinschaut weichen denken
konnte gegen den bordstein
ein skateboard ich meine ich bin echt
ist der beste als ob nach
ich find's klasse dass alle was gegen
ein skateboard haben und ich weg da
hinten irgendwo in der pampa auf dem
boden ich weiß das spiel mal bei anderen
user bestimmt viel mehr spaß zuschauen
allerdings kommt kommt ein radfahrer
doch schneller meine fresse ich kann mir
vorstellen dass das spiel bei vielen
youtube man einfach viel mehr spaß macht
zuzuschauen weil dies können die so kuck
dir meine videos man ich kann gar nicht
aber mir macht es viel spaß deswegen
wird definitiv über datei kommen und ja
wenn ihr das auch so sehen wollt haben
daumen hoch da ab sonntag gibt es immer
weniger von de
da siegt ihre sticker und wir sehen uns
dann